[Music]
here we go accent it was good it's
delicious
hey Joe ha this story here quite
interesting here yes Harry
yeah did you have a you have a tattoo of
his hair on your wrist yeah Oh Joe ha ha
ha ha
say Joe Bob say Joe say she's nice idea
an entanglement ok the story here talks
about how this family was handed their
who they thought was their father after
they were informed that the father had
passed away those ashes the body was
covered in a PPE suit and the face was
not visible so they did not know that
that was actually not their father and
then they found out that the father was
alive and I see you final rites that's
what they had claimed somebody died oh
but it wasn't their dad exactly so they
did a mix up is like a baby mix up this
man here oh it looks kind of similar
though this man here was handed over to
this man's family but then this man
ended up being alive where's that guy's
family men's families suing as well as
this family they're suing the hospital
because you're like what the [ __ ] you
play with our heart yeah motion in these
pictures they don't look the same but if
if one was dead probably look to say I
would say maybe right here look are are
both families soon yes I mean both
families got affected nah not really
yes because the family that buried that
man they did the whole like last rites
like the final final rites like the
funeral yeah yeah all that stuff they
mourned yeah they should actually found
that's now dig that full backup that's
not me I'm still dead reading it to do
the final day
I don't get why this one they just want
money out of it well there is a
complaint towards the the hospital and
so they're just trying to find out like
because they're just wanna do their job
they're trying they're not like did this
hot spider right so like malpractice its
malpractice isn't it that's not practice
they did say that it's really now is a
bad practice a bad practice yeah maybe
you want to say make up or call ill
practice true so this hospital is
running with only 30 percent staff it's
not their fault because they're
overworked [ __ ] [ __ ] over B
percent staff yes because the corona
virus is happening everybody got sick
this takes place in India by the way and
so like yeah and in India they're being
gravely affected by it covered poor
choice words or better good choice words
actually gravely is very good yes mmm
I actually should have seen that coming
yeah that's pretty if I got Corona it
was good yeah I'm good
it is I correct myself that was a sick
choice like the hospital don't visit me
at the hospital if I got Corona okay
nobody would yeah we wouldn't know about
two good sick choice words don't even
try it
yeah I mean no don't even visit me on
internet he just doesn't want he wants
to be alone no I don't want you to risk
getting Corona through the zoom either
so be careful it's usually not how I
work usually yeah you were the one I get
is probably gonna be strong virtual
Corona yeah Corona burst no it's it's
it's it's kind of dangerous right now
because California is supposed to be
having like the most ever and for the
longest time it was like what happened
man like California is not being
affected and true hey I [ __ ] out
of nowhere we had yesterday the the
highest reported case of thing they're
saying that were done keeps breaking the
record like you bet my butt yeah how
many more people are there like five oh
man oh six of us here so one of us is
[ __ ] one out of five people got Corona
know what I heard is that they're
limiting travel from Californians to
because like now New York and New Jersey
and all them are like if you come to our
state you got it what are you gonna do
I'm gonna be quarantined on a farm Wow
so it's like yeah I'm going out there
are you living your shirt
no no sugarcane yeah but mushroom
mushroom like to be continued I'm going
to a mushroom farm and I'm building
something special for the people to be
continued
yeah so like life and work I have to go
and visit the mushroom farm I have to
yeah you have to kind of do your own
thing if you're doing it safely I think
you're fine yeah yeah it's pretty easy
oh yeah your stories I got oysters
mushroom I gosh she Pocky
I just see mushrooms I don't like skip
skip yeah with this now what say the
next steps for the families well like I
said they're looking into exactly where
did it go wrong who's responsible and
they're gonna take actions but they're
saying that they just have not come to
any conclusion yet they're doing an
internal inquiry as to see like how did
a person that was not that family member
end up getting handed over to them so
they were saying that the hospital on
that same day there were four people
that had died and that's how they were
like well we got these other guys right
how did we [ __ ] up here so we're not a
four is not that bad is it
25% is pretty is pretty bad right 30%
yeah yeah hmm I don't know they got
different hospital not on 25% a failure
of identifying that person oh it's okay
all right judgment I took a back though
are you proud you were gravely wrong I
don't want to get sick in a different
country hell no why because most of them
are stupid why does it feel like you're
in Europe or somewhere with better
health care okay maybe if you're
afforded the help you do they give you
the health care though you know I mean I
think if you're golden oh not if you're
a citizen yourself video of American
that went there and then he like broke
his arm and they fixed them up and they
even gave him money for the to buy food
or take a taxi home what Wow where
Canada sounds like a London house
propaganda right there dude London I
heard they were [ __ ] up well I don't
know I just know that my friend in a
special Eastern European country told me
that they had to bribe the doctors to do
a good job so then they come in and they
go hey we got some whiskey for you
in some cigarettes and some extra money
you know cuz you work so hard so they
drink you before the surgeries I hope
not but I think it's a common practice
in this country I like braving the
flight attendants that's what it really
are you know I mean it was me please
land this time yeah the flight attendant
so fly
please services extra beverage
no it's please what is it up greatest
first class that grab Mike's point is
all the time I give them cash and they
give me another bottle yeah transaction
that's all buying I thought I was like a
secret menu thing cuz I found in the
book that they didn't tell me that was a
chocolates or something of value then
yeah oh yeah I gotta try that now but
this from yeah cousin want an economy if
they are your business with it I don't
know they'll take the chocolate now cuz
they'll be like you got Corona hands boy
but if I put a mask oh my god I'll put a
mask around the chocolate you get hand
sanitizer it has a box of chocolates
with a [ __ ] face mask on it like this
yeah honestly the considerateness of
that I don't know that's what
considerateness yeah I would take it I'd
like Dan you thought about this yeah but
what did Turkish flight attendants
Turkish coffee Turkish Airlines they
want Turkish Airlines yeah please I'm
not getting business okay just the
regular do they have TV on the back oh
yeah you've flown Turkish Airlines
business class hi how come you always
chose it or was it just lucky it's the
international hub out there yeah yeah so
it like for coming back from our wedding
for example that one was from Europe and
we went to Croatia going there coming
back that was that and then what kind of
food do you care how was it cuz it's I
never think about Turkish Airlines this
honnor standard tank but what kind of
fish we go lounge cooler cooler than
Singapore Airlines blender if you get
admitted to the lounge if I stumble
right yeah
yeah yeah you don't get in there to
lounge there's so many people that it's
just like a crazy Airport but when you
get into the lounge there's the nice
lounge i've ever been in
it's like a small it's [ __ ] huge
business class lounges are sick though
I'm staying at the hotel summer to
airport these have a 13 hour layover
there no they have no they actually
shuttle you throw away whatever because
we did that too one time we flew so well
in business think if they take you to
this really nice fancy ass hotel it's
right by the ocean or the water and and
then like that the room is so [ __ ]
nice but then when we flew economy they
take you a shitty ass like motel looking
thing and it's like in the middle of the
city and I was like oh man there's a
there's a very very strong contrast all
I know it is and I wonder what the
difference is from business at first oh
I know first class on this whole
different beast mm-hmm we got we went to
Istanbul four times and we've only ever
seen the hotel we've never seen the city
oh yeah yeah oh you're gonna assemble
I'm going to failure or Antalya so you
have to go to the airport and then
boo-yeah is BAM [ __ ] and then you go
to a fella
Filippo fire you're doing your teeth
yeah we talked about this I haven't been
here every episode you've been in nobody
we've talked to you on that so that we
talked about I don't remember Nadine
you're like that
he's gonna get a teeth in a boob job
it's good yeah I mean veneers oh it's
cheaper it's better it's quicker and
they have really cool hookers out there
do they they just came out I don't know
dangerous do they I don't know oh don't
forget to get a visa before before you
leave the airport already cuz they're
[ __ ] mean if you don't have it
why because oh you need to be so before
you go to like this ATM thing you get it
like a 20 20 $40 visa or some [ __ ] I did
online
have you guys ever had a Turkish cotton
yeah what is it like we got it together
we did with that one hook up plays ham
Tran bought it for us it was strong I
don't remember I just remembered the tea
the herb all I know is it
I do like that cool like food and
cutting videos they're all from like
Turkey oh man I wish I was gone what you
dude
we gonna go I can't believe you can go
they open up in like a few days I'm
hoping they still allow Americans when
did you book your appointment uh like a
month ago but they're like oh we there
because they don't even know when
they're opened up so they're like not
they kept pushing it back to the
hospital have like a couple of months
ago live your best life and clean your
teeth man yeah I know I did hear that
turkeys like another plastic surgery hub
yeah well cuz in America imagine like
how like say you need a inhalers a
couple hundred bucks when you go
anywhere else it's not that expensive
Mexico man yeah so then but is it the
same though yeah same drug same exact
drug in Turkey they have like so much
just something they do is like so nice
the doctors that they don't ball ah they
don't not driving like crazy nice cars
like they do out here because here it's
the same thing that a tooth here cost
like one or three thousand and then it
takes like over a month to get the whole
procedure so why don't they just come
here the cost difference of flying out
over theirs paying for a state doing all
that versus for the my work I mean done
I'm gonna spin around in total value
like ten thousand here it would be like
40,000 plus out the way like a month or
two thousand yeah damn what like the
wedding industry it's cheaper and other
places them in forty thousand why was it
cheaper for you to get a thing in a
France yeah everyone thinks our wedding
was like [ __ ] insanely extra because
I look beautiful exactly look beautiful
though but it would have been way more
expensive we had that's the trade
wedding here why what's the treasure so
much for nothing you know yeah that's
true it does for everything and we got
shitty products here yeah yeah like the
buildings everything yeah it's crazy but
people say our clothes are cheap like
rename brands and all that stuff Oh
compared to now like sourced out of
country hmm that's why a lot of people
like shopping in the states cuz like if
you get the same thing in Australia or
Europe or whatever they're not like
luxury tax so if want to buy a Gucci
shirt it's just whatever the Gucci
prices oh yeah saying that the quality
is saying got you yes
technically a South Korean Airport
Incheon that's what that please has a
moment like one of the best places to
get any luxury arms even cheaper than
America by like sometimes 20-30 percent
and their authentic authentic yet it
makes sense just to fly there to buy
like a bunch of [ __ ] roller yeah well
literally we're there with these
gigantic black like empty suitcases and
then they're filling them up like
throwing away all the packaging and like
filling up they're so cool
whoa they were buying up their paint and
cosmetics to the cosmetic machine yeah
in clinic oh yeah like at the airport
like I see their women all the time that
just cite their hold the more than their
luggage is just makeup I feel like I
need to buy something I just don't know
what to buy so I didn't buy anything and
when you travel yeah when I went to
Korea for yourself yeah for myself like
what do you mean like you know like like
beauty products so many people are
taking advantage or like that's because
you're beautiful oh because you don't
need it so you walk in you're like oh I
think you need it happy expensive bags
though yeah you missed out [ __ ]
[Music]